Let's also do a quiz
about the miss rate.
Keep in mind that the hit rate is
equal to one minus the miss rate.
The miss rate is how often
do we have a cash miss.
The hit rate is how often
do we have a cash hit, and
the two adapt to one because we
either have one or the other.
So which of the following are true for
a well designed cache?
Is it true that in a well designed cache
the hit rate should be larger than
the miss rate, the hit rate should
be less than the miss rate,
that the hit and the miss rate should be
balanced, as close to equal as possible,
that the hit rate should be almost one,
that the miss rate should be almost one?
Again, more than one, possibly all,
possibly none of them might be true, so
check all of those that are true for
a well designed cache.